foreign
crypto derivatives platform and the best
place to buy your Bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the layer
heilpan show today we're talking all
about whether the bull market is back
and when that might be but before we get
into this I do want to let you know that
it is sponsored by bitmax the OG crypto
derivatives exchange that now actually
has a spot exchange for you to buy and
sell all your crypto especially in a
bear Market you definitely need a name
that you can trust a bitmax sets a
standard in reliability performance and
transparency and it's proven itself
through multiple Market Cycles so I'm
going to leave all the links for you in
the description
um so definitely join bimax the number
one place to grab some Bitcoin during
the market crash now before I do bring
on my guests please don't forget to hit
the like button and subscribe so you
never miss a video alright guys let's
find out when the bull market is coming
back joining me today is crypto YouTuber
entrepreneur and very successful Trader
it's Chris or as everyone else knows him
it's mm crypto welcome to the show how
you doing
hey thanks for having me I'm doing very
well how are you today
I'm good thank you I'm so excited to
chat with you I see you all over the
Internet with your emergency posts so
I'm just really excited to exactly
there's the base so I'm super excited to
get into this
um I want to kick this off just by
talking about Dubai you're based out
there what's it like I know everybody's
out there at the moment like what are
you doing all day in Dubai
yeah first of all thanks for having me
and actually your stuff pops up also on
my Tick Tock so some of your videos
called viral AF I think you're doing a
great job and I'm very sure you have an
awesome audience and I'm happy to be on
this channel
um to answer your question I went to
Dubai in 2019 actually and first of all
I thought okay I might as well set up my
residency and stuff but now I'm like
living there right
um currently I'm traveling but in
general it is I think the number one
place for crypto jumps off Network in
terms of regulations you can open a
company like this they have very nice
tax benefits you can buy a Lamborghini
and crypto you can buy a Ferrari
everything encrypt you can pay your rent
in crypto it's like really really
awesome and when it comes to crypto it's
really the number one I think
that's amazing I can't wait to get into
all of that um I'm so interested in what
life is like regulations being able to
just spend your crypto
um but we'll get back to Dubai I want to
kind of give everyone what they're
wondering um because before we get into
Bitcoin um and the rest of the market I
saw a tweet of yours which I thought was
really inspiring you said four and a
half years ago I was a taxi driver and
now this thank you with an orange heart
so I assume that's sort of referencing
Bitcoin can you take us from the
beginning where were you a taxi driver
how long were you doing this and how did
you go from Taxi Driver to Trader
yeah it's it's a pretty humble story I I
posed with this like a year ago and this
video blew up on Twitter like crazy I
think it got like three point something
million views
um and yeah people were probably
fascinated about the story I have I
lived in Germany I studied economics by
the way I dropped out of school started
again and then like I dropped out of two
Bachelor of Science Bachelor of law
yeah that's it and then the last one I
actually made um Bachelor of Arts and
economics and then I studied the master
until I found Bitcoin
um however before I found Bitcoin or
around this time and three years before
I was driving a taxi on the weekend to
actually finance my living right and the
week I was studying on the weekend I was
driving a taxi because also I was doing
a lot of party back in the days and I
wanted a reason not to party anymore I
wanted to reason to save money so I
found the work which was on the weekend
and that was taxi driving
um yeah once I found about out about
Bitcoin I quit taxi because I saved
money I put some money on the sidelines
not much but I quit taxi I quit my
Master's University dropped out once
again and the money I had half I put
into Bitcoin and some altcoins and then
invested in icos and stuff like someone
who follows me for day one knows this
already and the other half actually kept
so I knew if I start now investing I
need some money to eat so I actually we
spend only a thousand dollars per um per
month just on like food and um the cheap
rent I had
because I knew it's gonna take a few
months until I make money and actually I
never put money out of place uh the
moment I made my first like good profits
and my first money also business-wise
was basically after like 10 12 months
the moment I was broke so um that was
really Destiny uh being here in my favor
and um yeah I'm very very proud to look
back at these very humble beginnings me
like eating potatoes at home and saving
money until I can finally be successful
and you know yourself in crypto it's
like once the seat explodes it just goes
it just goes everything goes together
and it works out
that is such a crazy story I'm so
excited to find out you know like how
you knew um you know what coins to buy
what icos and we're going to get into
all that but before we do um I want to
know your take on where we are right now
in the market what is going on should
people be buying Bitcoin should they be
holding should they be selling
um do you think we're going lower or are
we about to explode into a bear Market a
bull market in the new year
answer to the question what is going on
is probably nothing right I mean
everyone who looks into the charts sees
nothing is going on if you pull out the
volatility indicators it's basically
just going sideways for five months and
I do not recall any point of time in
history where this happened we always
have like some kind of flat bear Market
also in um November 2018 when we
bottomed out at three thousand
it took uh quite some time until we
actually got this breakout towards the
upside I think it was April 2019 five
months later now again five months who
knows
um but at least we had some steady
upwards movement right now it's like
literally the most boring time since I
started and that was way more than like
five years ago and
um I think that is a good time actually
for people to look into Bitcoin whoever
is watching this and it's not exposed
yet
when it's the most boring the longer we
go sideways the more the the more
duration we are in a low volatility
phase the bigger the break is going to
be and if you are looking at the
economics if you look at the Keynesian
economics at the monetary policy and you
see that U.S dollar is getting printed
euro is getting printed we are coming to
inflation later so I don't want to take
too much away here but if you know what
Bitcoin was designed for then you know
it's not gonna go sideways forever
because there is actually a pump behind
Bitcoin which is gonna catapult it into
the into the sky and that is inflation
and that is actually that people need
Bitcoin Bitcoin is a solution so I don't
really care about the low volatility I
don't really care if okay maybe 17.5 was
not the bottom which I think it was the
bottom if we go down to 15 whatever like
for me what Bitcoin stays from Bitcoin I
am in Bitcoin for one specific reason
and that is to exit the traditional
Financial system so whoever incorporates
that in their mindset actually doesn't
get crazy but about this and will not go
crazy when it goes lower just scoop up
as many Bitcoin as you can and as you
can afford to lose in the worst case no
Financial advice and I think then in a
few years we'll all be having laughing
faces yeah much um yeah you just have to
have that long-term view
um so how long do you think the bear
Market will last
I mean the bear Market was lasting
technically even since April 2021
actually because when we topped out at
64 000 until then we went down and we
went to 69 so technically it was a
higher high but in the meantime we had
more inflation actually already so the
price went another eight percent higher
or whatever but we had like at least
eight percent inflation in most of the
countries in the us alone we probably
had inofficially also eight percent
inflation so we didn't really create a
new high uh I think the bull market high
was actually in April to in terms of
purchasing power April 2021 and that is
one and a half years ago that is already
one of the longest bear markets ever and
I think it is it has ended at 17.5 if
this was the bottom technically it was
the end of the bear market and I just
really also believe that within the next
one to two months we will see some
volatility and I believe and hope that
it's is going to be in our favor so
towards the upside to answer your
question I think the bear Market is
going on for a long time and I think
technically it's over and the feeling
that it's over will come within the next
few weeks
I hope you're right I mean I also have
that long-term perspective but it's just
awful seeing you know your money just
like declining in value with inflation
and everything it's just it's not it's
not fun
um so Bitcoin aside obviously you're
very bullish on bitcoin but
um what are you the most bullish on long
term and how do you make that decision
like how do you how do you pick
different coins
I am actually the most bullish on
bitcoin of course Bitcoin doesn't have
the highest upside right yes you have
other things with a higher upside but
you have also a much bigger risk in
return right you have this Bitcoin sign
in the back probably for a very good
reason Bitcoin is the safest to invest
in in the crypto space the face safest
the safest to transact which with and I
think safety is what people are looking
out for now and in the future if you
look for the biggest upside we go on
coin market cap and we scroll to the
very back but this has a very high
likelihood of going to zero for me
personally I think at this point of time
and that is my personal opinion the
probability of Bitcoin going to zero is
almost zero percent
it's almost zero percent I have to say
it legally but I really really don't see
it and the upside now let's talk about
the upside if Bitcoin becomes the global
World Reserve currency we heard it
probably multiple times I said it since
like three four years now you have
Michael sailor and everyone talking
about it also then we are looking at a
price of at least one million dollars
per Bitcoin and actually more
realistically four or five million US
dollars per Bitcoin which would be a
hundred trillion US dollar market cap so
if we are looking at the one million
dollar right which is of course for
everyone who's not in crypto watching me
right now things like that stupid moon
boy but a million dollars that's a 50x
upside
and your downside is a hundred percent
which is honestly speaking not even a
high probability scenario so if your
downside is a hundred percent but your
upside is 50x
like I do not have to search for for
anything else of course I hold some
altcoins I even bought Dogecoin with the
Elon Musk yeah I put 400k into Dodge
Coin I know it's maybe stupid but I just
like to play but honestly my main main
focus is on bitcoin and then of course
I'm looking into ethereum and I'm
looking into some altcoins I'm investing
into seed rounds I bought some updos and
so on so I'm looking at these things but
my main focus also in terms of my
portfolio is Bitcoin and it will stay
Bitcoin I'm not gonna get shaken out of
that because people got shaken out 2011
they got checking out 2014 2018-19 I'm
not one of them it doesn't matter I have
Bitcoin goes to 10 000 I'm gonna get
more money and I'm gonna buy more
Bitcoin
I love the conviction so you gave us a
price prediction one million dollars do
you have a time frame on this and then
you said five million so what's your
time frame yeah I said five million
would be 100 trillion US Dollars
technically that that would be a
possible scenario uh if Bitcoin becomes
the world Reserve currency or like
really globally adopted then five
million dollars is I would say at the
current purchasing power maybe at the
moment it's already 6 million that would
be the best case scenario let's look at
one million uh as a more realistic
scenario and for this I would look out
for a few years down the line what we
need for this is of course a little bit
more regulatory Clarity and many many
other countries we got a little bit more
from the US already
um Dubai and like many other countries
are coming after that so this is looking
good but I would look at at least a few
more years down the line and I want to
be honest two years ago my my time wise
my target was much earlier but I want to
be a little bit more realistic so
um two thousand
like it's not the next talk about the
cycle afterwards let's say 2026 2027 for
for like a one million dollar Bitcoin
damn I hope you're right that'll be
incredible
um you mentioned ethereum so what's your
take on proof of stake versus proof of
work obviously that was the merge has
that changed your opinion on each
because it sort of changed my opinion
slightly
yeah so let's look first of all at the
economic and incentive structure point
of view so in general if you look at the
concept it's it's a good thing people
are incentivized to stake their ethereum
they basically take it from the
circulating Supply right also we
basically have a deflation because
more ethereum upon than like more coming
into circulation right so that's also
economically a good thing as we need
scarcity for the price to increase
Bitcoin always had more scarcity as um
the inflation rate was much lower and
before Bitcoin ethereum had like a
constant inflation at a constant number
of ethereum being mined every year so
that's a good thing right but personally
I prefer proof of work for the long term
and in terms of security so that's why
if I had to choose I would prefer
ethereum to stay proof of work but um I
mean I hold 20 off my portfolio in
ethereum I like the economic point the
economic incentive structure behind it I
like the added scarcity because that was
the biggest downside of ethereum was not
scarce at all with the current inflation
so um it has pros and cons in terms of
security and in terms of
um like Grassroots crypto thinking I
think proof of work is better but
because I don't really care about the
environmental aspect to be honest not
that I don't care about the environment
but I know that most of the mining is
coming from renewable energy anyways and
there is a cost to security and um and a
great Network like Bitcoin and there
must be a cost so anyways in total I
think it is probably economically a good
thing and I'm still holding my ethereum
and I'm still bullish on ethereum
yeah no I agree with you I think the
environmental concerns are just like
made up concerns to take down Bitcoin
it's yeah it's all rubbish in my opinion
it's not working out anyways I don't
think anyone really believes that who
who understands Bitcoin oh yeah
absolutely I think currently like 52 of
Bitcoin mining uses renewable energy
which is obviously better for the
environment anyway so
yeah I don't think that they're fooling
anyone just yet um but there's a lot of
amazing sector while they are burning
right sorry for interrupting but no
you're right and and the gold industry
banking you know it's it's so much more
and nobody this is like slavery
partially right yeah yeah and they don't
say anything about it which is why I
always think there's like an alternative
agenda at play do you think there's like
an alternative agenda at play to take
down because it's always an alternative
agenda and play yeah well we could get
into that we can get into that um on
camera not on camera okay all right fair
enough
I do talk about a lot of this stuff
actually I do get into all of it so I
always have to and I had one of my
videos actually taken down the other day
because I spoke about the alternative
agenda and who runs at least on Twitter
it's not gonna be taken down now that
Elon musket the lead that's true that's
true let's get your take on that while
we're here what do you think about Elon
Musk and the the state of censorship
right now um online
awesome awesome for a long time I was I
was actually I have ADHD so I don't
really read but I was listening to the
audiobook of his um biography like this
this book about him and I was I was
being like almost a fan a few years ago
and then I was questioning sometimes but
at this point of time I'm a big fan I
think he's awesome he's funny AF
um I love his memes I laughed all of his
plans he's really thinking outside of
the cosmos really like wants to make the
human man and multiplanetary species
like I really really think he's funny
and I think his Twitter move was
extremely smart if he's getting people
to um pay eight dollars a month and you
get like tens of millions of users or
like maybe a hundred million users to it
800 million per month that's a crazy
crazy model let's see how this plays out
but in general I think it's a great
thing and I also like the new leadership
now which is not so I I don't want to
like offend anyone watching here but uh
probably yeah so many people from this
Camp anyways watching but it was really
very very very left-winged leadership in
Twitter and you saw all of these fact
checks oh my always on the other side of
the news but now finally we saw the
White House was tweeting something and
you had a fact check below the White
House tweet about the White House
posting that there is like this senior
payment increase the biggest one in
history thanks to Biden and then there
was the the fact check below it and I
think finally we get some fairness some
some fairness on on at least one social
media and that really makes me happy to
see and I hope that's gonna be a trend
in the future and we just need one
central point where people can come and
gain some like some some clear and
honest information and um when we get
people more educated I know you and I we
are and many of you the viewers probably
are also but when we get the Masters
more educated
um on on the truth I think the future is
gonna be more bright
yeah I totally agree with you um I think
that was also so funny I I saw somebody
say misinformation
um I don't know something about
misinformation and protected speech and
then you have like this fact check
saying like no the First Amendment
defends freedom of speech it's just it's
I know I felt the same way over the last
few days were the funniest of my life in
terms of online like when I go on
Twitter I've never laughed so much did
you see this this skit of the two guys
in front of the Twitter thing where this
guy said I have to go to my husband and
wife and no I didn't see it oh wow I'm
gonna send it to you so everyone who
didn't watch it look out for it online
to supposedly
um Twitter employees were fired but it
was actors actually acting as if they
were Twitter employees and they said
some really funny things unfortunately
you didn't see it I'm gonna send it over
but many funny things happened on
Twitter everyone who's on Twitter will
probably agree yeah no it's amazing what
do you think then you know if Elon Musk
is gonna potentially Protect free speech
um what do you think like the future of
web 3 is because web3 is all about you
know decentralizing the internet
protecting people from being censored
um but I feel a little bit weird about
web3 I feel a little bit like they're
just going to be web 2
um but web3 in terms of like having a
monopoly over everything and just buying
up everything and
cooling the shots themselves
yeah I'm not 100 sure if I understood
the question
oh sorry so so if if we have Elon Musk
um promoting Free Speech what do you
think the future of web 3 is then do you
think it sort of becomes redundant or do
you think that web3 wasn't really going
to promote Free Speech anyway ah for web
3 we have so many different use cases
right
um I think if if you have not only
social media you have like remittance
and like so many different use cases so
um if One Wing of like one one part of
web 3 supports the same agenda as Elon
Musk supports with taking over Twitter
it's gonna be good it's it's going into
the the current is flowing into the same
direction but web3 has so many different
use cases so I see just like some small
interconnection there but in in general
you um you'll I did I think there will
be even like web3 integrated in in
Twitter of course but there are like so
many different use cases so I think web3
is like a much bigger topic yeah okay no
that's interesting um I just figured you
know because the sort of the pendulum is
moving the other way
um with the likes of Elon Musk promoting
freedom of speech so I'm just sort of
wondering where web3 is going to go um
well a lot of it is being built on
ethereum you gave us your bitcoin price
prediction I hate to put you on the hot
seat again but can you give us an
ethereum price prediction a year from
now five years from now what do you
think
well if Bitcoin would reach the like in
in five years would reach a million
dollars that would be a 50x right so
since ethereum's market cap is
significantly lower I think a much lower
probability scenario but still a
possible one for ethereum would be maybe
like thirty thousand forty thousand I
personally think that long-term Bitcoin
is going to outperform ethereum short
term I think um ethereum is going to get
another nice push outper from Bitcoin
but long term I think Bitcoin is going
to stay the number one and um ethereum
is still going to be amazing everyone
who's holding ethereum now is probably
going to be very happy in a few years
um but I don't see if Bitcoin makes a
50x I don't see like a 60 70 80x for for
ethereum happening uh to be honest okay
so good both of them are good bets in
the in the short term
personally for me I think yes but of
course I was wrong in the past long term
I'm right I'm very sure about this and
so far I was very correct long term but
short term I can be I can be wrong
um as I said
like if there's extra it's not only the
inflation which determines the bit
Converse not only the US dollar Index
you have exogenous risk factors if a
drop hopefully never ever but Bob
dropped somewhere or something like
Global certainty breaks out boom we
break down like it can be many things
some big politician says one wrong thing
on social media and we get a big wick to
the downside
um it's it's very difficult to to
predicted these exogenous risk factors
but with these factors excluded I think
from here we should see upside
yeah I think it's so difficult short
time to make those predictions the world
is so unpredictable right now inflation
is still unpredictable well actually
inflation is predictable which is going
up
um but you know everything else with
with Wars and everything like that is
all pretty unpredictable
um let's get into inflation because the
cost of living is obviously going up in
your opinion how can people prepare do
you think that crypto is the answer
[Music]
for inflation to tackle inflation yes
hundred percent I mean crypto in general
not necessarily because we have so many
different concepts within crypto what we
need is a scarce crypto which is not
confiscatable which is um durable which
has no borders right and like all of
these things I think they apply to
bitcoin of course you need uh Global
acceptance right you need um security of
the network so I would say to tackle
inflation Bitcoin is probably the best
if you want to build a project if you
want like for these things ethereum is
better
want to buy your verification on Twitter
for eight dollars probably Dodge con is
the best but in general I have to tackle
inflation Bitcoin is the best yes
because we have
basically the price of Bitcoin is
determined by demand and supply and the
supply of Bitcoin is fixed then you have
the Demand right which now how much
percent of the population is exposed to
bitcoin three four percent so
potentially the the upside is still 95
96 there is such a long way to go even
though a lot of network be and high net
worth people are already involved but
there's a long way to go but there's
another actually another another Factor
going into this calculation and that is
what it is denominated and it's
denominated in US dollar and the base
the denomination the base of the
denomination US dollar is getting
inflated so this is another Force
pushing the price higher so I'm very
very certain that Bitcoin is the answer
to inflation and many people understand
this also just if you pull out some data
of correlation between inflation and the
Bitcoin price so I'll look at Argentina
turkey with the Turkish lira Zimbabwe
many of these countries some more than
others they have a very big um very big
correlation between the inflation rate
in the specific country and the adoption
rate of Bitcoin if you go to Turkey and
you ask Emmy and I'm telling you Emmy
yeah Turkish guy between 18 and 30 every
single one of them has a binance account
every single one like let's say 99 out
of a hundred really I have Turkish kols
they made service and everything
everyone has a binance account over
there and the Turkish lira was actually
losing a lot of value towards um US
dollar and one very important thing
people have to understand is we are
looking at all of these countries I
actually was talking about it five years
ago already or four years ago because I
did study economics I was not only a
taxi driver and I do understand
something about economics and I was
already seeing okay we have Zimbabwe we
have all of these third world countries
actually having their currency inflated
and depreciating against the U.S dollar
then I said at this point of time I said
it online and to many of my friends the
names will be brick states it would be
second world countries Argentina and
stuff all of these ones were already
like in the making and going turkey was
coming so now these ones had actually a
very um big depreciation against the US
dollar and then I said the next one is
going to be the First World countries
that's gonna be Euro and eventually the
US dollar euro and the Great British
pound they were actually already
depreciating a lot in value against the
US dollar
so now everyone is saying wow the US
dollar is so strong everything is
falling against the US dollar what we
have to understand is all of these
currencies all of them are falling
knives some are falling faster than the
others but the US dollar is falling off
so it's just falling a little bit slower
than the other ones because you have so
many countries trading oil in in US
dollar so many countries being packed to
the U.S dollar which increases the the
demand behind it and the stability
behind it but eventually all of them are
going to fail because all Fiat
currencies have failed in the history of
mankind they never lasted more than 70
years so the US dollar lost its pack to
the dollar 1971 which was like 51 years
ago so the time is ticking yeah and we
see all of these falling knives and once
they hit the ground the last one is
hitting the ground and that's going to
be the U.S solar I'm not 100 sure about
that but I'm just looking at the
Historical confidence level which is a
hundred percent for every single fiat
currency created
so what happens when that happens so
they're all falling knives I love the
analogy but what happens in the US
dollar that knife just Falls is there
like this huge shock the system
collapses like
what do we see
very very difficult to predict very
difficult to predict to be honest but
it's not going to be nice that is for
sure we can already see what is
happening when um we see very high rates
of inflation or hyperinflation in some
countries like
I don't know Zimbabwe and stuff right
where people are not going to be not not
able anymore to to afford the food
because the next day it's gonna be
already double the price triple the
price 10 times the price eventually like
in Germany people had to carry the money
in like big big wagons to to like buy
some bread so what happens is of course
there is going to be a shortage of
Supply in the supermarkets and stuff and
the prices are increasing like crazy so
unfortunately and
um I hope it's not gonna be like that
but very high likely scenario is that
the lower and lower class and the lower
middle class are going to be the victims
of that so that is why it is very
important to be prepared and at least
whatever you are willing to lose or you
can afford to lose you're not never
willing to lose but what you can afford
to lose
I would put it personally in Bitcoin you
might as well put it in Gold also it's
not a bad BET right like small gold
boxes or something not Not a Bad Bet but
um I would personally definitely put
something in Bitcoin and if that's like
10 a month or something and you're only
able to afford to lose that ten dollars
a month so this is fine if we actually
hit if like if you lose it it's ten
dollars you're losing on your monthly
investment but if we are hitting the 1
million US Dollars which is not a
scenario completely out in the sky then
500 uh ten dollars turn into 500 every
ten dollars you put in turn into 500 so
I personally think Bitcoin is a very
very good hatch against inflation and
risk return wise I think it's the best
strategy to go if you are young
um or if you're not if you're not like
90 years old and if you if you can
afford to lose these small Investments
I'm also inspired from that speech I
feel like all the leftover uh Great
British pounds they have I need to just
like throw into Bitcoin for after this
conversation
um because yeah I mean even my pounds
are like losing value against the dollar
um which just sucks because I'm they
were always so strong right yeah it was
all it always always like as a kid every
time I traveled to the states everything
was half price for me almost half price
now
yeah almost yeah almost and so now
um I don't used to go and like buy all
like the designer clothes half price and
everything in the States but now it's
yeah it's quite unbelievable
um out of interest
um I know that you're a crypto day
trader do you trade any equities or
bonds um I know I see you every day and
you you say today on the Bitcoin price
I'm not going to try to do the accent I
can't do the accent
um but I see you every day saying that
so is it just crypto or do you trade
anything else
uh I actually just trade crypto I mean I
did when I was before I got into crypto
on a very very small level as I said I
was a student I had some stocks but I
wasn't even trading them I was just like
value investing but at this point of
time only crypto it's 24 7 it's high
liquidity I understand it and that's the
only thing I'm doing I'm not gonna be
like
going out and trying different because
Bitcoin gets a little bit boring right
now yeah yeah no that makes sense um so
can you tell me some classic chart
analysis that I should look out for and
if that everyone else should look out
for if we want to buy or sell Bitcoin
just some obvious trading Basics I've
heard the head and shoulder pattern a
dead cat bounce cup and handle what do
these mean tell me like what I should
look out for oh they are like they are
like a thousand things usually like most
people they go on the pattern side they
just Google pattern side bulkovsky it's
a free website with knowledge like all
different patterns but they are like 200
I
I shouldn't even start with that okay I
think if anyone is getting into it the
most interesting thing is for me
personally especially right now the
higher time frames just put it on the
monthly and you will see Bitcoin is
following a very similar pattern every
single time even though things seem
different we are going through the same
thing people went through in 2018 19 and
2014 and 2011. so um
once again the website if you want to
see some chart patterns otherwise I
would recommend on-train fundamental
indicators that's a beautiful thing this
has never existed before now we have an
open Ledger like Bitcoin blockchain with
all public data and you can actually get
indications indicators out of the
Bitcoin blockchain if you are reading
the Bitcoin watch and you can see when
Bitcoin were moved at what price was it
a big wallet moving it a small wallet
moving it so you can see is a whale
moving his money are many whales moving
their money I was moving the money to an
exchange are they moving it in a profit
are they moving it not in a profit and I
think this is really really valuable
data and it's really valuable insights
something which we never had before and
um as long as not everyone is using it
it's still working and I can tell you
one thing they wear a separate bullish
right now and um I am pretty bullish at
the moment as well okay amazing
um how do you deal with the pressure of
trading are you up all night watching
the charts what kind of temperament does
an individual have to have in order to
be a Trader because I hear a lot of
people say when they're day trading they
don't say more than five words a day to
someone because they're just there
staring at the charts yeah that's not me
I mean I'm I'm personally not even a day
trader I'm a position Trader so what I
do is if the Bitcoin price moves like
crazy and hits like a big support level
of mine then I scale and start scaling
in with a long position for example in a
bear Market I open it if it goes lower I
scale it up I put more in into the same
position and once the market turns I
have a long position
at this like potential low or close to
the low and then I just ride it for
weeks and sometimes for months right now
I have if someone watches my channel I
show it almost every video I have a long
position open which is open for
for many many many many weeks and that
is usually my trading strategy so I can
sleep well I don't have to watch the
charts all the time and if the Bitcoin
price crashes crazy or pumps like crazy
and everyone is very bullish for
everyone is very bearish this is when I
get active one time and then I sit back
relax and enjoy the profits good that's
how it should be I just it just blows my
mind that people are just there up all
night you know bags under their eyes
just stressing watching the charts it's
just it's so unhealthy there's no
endurance to it um so how do you know
when to cut your losses because a lot of
people get really emotionally attached
to a trade how do you how do you know
when to cut your losses
well usually that's when the liquidation
hits then then I'm out of the trade but
I usually I put a stop loss just before
the liquidation to save some fees
because on a liquidation the fees are
higher so for the stop loss uh just
above the liquidation and then when I'm
out I'm out and then I'm not gonna trade
for a little bit because I know then
otherwise emotions are involved you get
into Revenge trading and emotions are
involved most likely you are going to be
making mistakes right so whenever I get
wiped out of a trade I lean back and I
chill it a bit until I I gain some
distance to the to the whole meta again
and then I start trading but um yeah I I
never really had a problem with like oh
I want to put in more when I get back my
money
um this is like Gambler Gambler
mentality and I lost my Gambler
mentality five years ago so yeah okay
well that's important
um you know taking a break so that you
don't trade emotionally I think that's
important with anything even like in
business in relationships just breaking
when something happens and then allowing
the emotions to pass so then you can
think logically As you move forward
um yeah no definitely I want to kind of
get uh know a little bit more about you
on a personal level because you're
originally from Germany so can you tell
me why you chose to move to Dubai of all
places what are the benefits from a
business a personal standpoint like
what's the lifestyle like in Dubai
well first of all it's it's easy to get
there right if you're good and clean
person you go there you open a bank
account you open a company just like
that you have insane tax benefits right
everyone has to check for themselves and
um consult your own tax advisors and
whatever but in general you have very
awesome tax advantages in Dubai and the
number one thing is safety right we just
talked about the UK
um things are going really bad and the
reason is of course because of the
economy I mean since 2020 March the the
governments of all different countries
made these very bad decisions with like
no travel and all of these things they
really hurt the economy unemployment
rates were at like Skyrocket High the
this was the biggest recession we just
didn't see it because the prices
continued skyrocketing afterwards but
the economy was doing really bad and
people were starving and they're still
starving we still see the big aftermath
from that so crime rates increased
significantly in whole Europe in the USA
and of course in all the other countries
as well as people are starving more and
uh going more into poverty right so we
are seeing all of these very sad
developments happening and Dubai gives
you definitely a high amount of safety
which becomes more and more a very
important topic nowadays right so that
is very important then of course service
is clean
um everything has a good structure and
the network is crazy right I mean
yesterday we were just like on a table
all together other and then like we got
a FaceTime call and there was Steven
Seagal Andrew Tate and like all sitting
in Dubai uh on on an iPhone smiling to
us and like these things only in Dubai
right I go somewhere I meet like an
actor I meet this I go to a networking
event to a birthday and I meet like
people with 30 million followers people
with 10 million followers I read like a
class actors football players I played
with them with a German World Champion
we played football now we are friends
like these things only in Dubai I mean
maybe in Beverly Hills but yeah then you
have some other downsides right so
um I really really like Dubai for that I
like many other countries for other
things I like Thailand for the nature
for the mentality and all of these
things
um but Dubai is for crypto I think the
go-to place right now yeah Dubai's
fascinating I feel like Dubai right now
is the place you sort of go once you've
made good money and you're ready just to
like be around like-minded individuals
who all sort of want to have a good nice
clean life it's so interesting because
like you said the world did shut down
and it was just so crazy and Dubai
seemed to be the only place which is
um welcoming the new world in in a good
way whether it's crypto whether it's
um you know just affluence and safety
and and things like that um so do you
think Dubai is going to be in a league
of its own as we move into this sort of
like dark dystopian future which I feel
like we're moving into
well definitely at the moment they are
the the the strongest pushing for that
but eventually this is a model which is
succeeding for like two three years more
than before it was they are succeeding
since like tens of years but uh in the
last few years they were succeeding much
more than others So eventually I think
they will be copied right but uh in in
many regards like especially in regards
of safety it's not so easy to copy that
but in many other regards I think they
will be copied so um I I truly hope it's
not gonna be the only place because I
wish the best for the world and for
everyone living somewhere else also and
I really hope that these these sad
developments are not going to continue
outside of of Dubai like in other
countries
I think the safety is such an
interesting point because a lot of
people keep um bringing that up I speak
to a lot of people that are based there
um and they talk about how everybody's
too afraid to step out of line whereas
like the police in the United Kingdom
are like they seem very soft and they
seem you know to be like they're
involved in like the gay pride events
and they're like dancing and singing and
like how can you take law enforcement
seriously you know what I mean if
they're not I'm excited yeah you've not
seen this no yeah yeah what's news I can
only see it on Twitter or YouTube but I
didn't see it yeah like law enforcement
is there like holding hands and like you
know dancing and they're like one of the
people it's like how are you supposed to
take Law and Order seriously if you're
not afraid you know is there like a
level of being afraid in Dubai is that
what it is
um well you definitely respect the law
if you live there right you want to
respect the law and you want to play by
the rules and um if that means not like
uh littering not like like stealing I
mean that that is things which you
should which you shouldn't do in the
first place right so in general their
law system is to be taken serious it is
to be respected but if the general
principles behind it are just common
sense I think it's very easy to follow
it right and um the reason why people
follow it is people because people do
respect it and maybe there's some kind
of fear involved because you know if
you're gonna mess up the punishment is
usually pretty pretty heavy
um it's so interesting I mean I do hope
that that is adopted
um okay so just finally I see flexing a
lot on social media
um and you have to tell us like how many
cars do you have how many watches do you
have you know and what's your favorite
car I just I see it all over social so I
kind of I kind of want to know yeah I
was flexing a little bit in the bull
markets in on the palm and like some
cars
um I had I had a lot of cars I actually
sold recently McLaren Xena at the moment
I only have my G-Class mansuri which is
sikka it's like a one out of one I have
a Bentley
a luxury van bendy mansuri and the
luxury van with like a toilet and like
massage seats
pretty cool but that's already it then I
have a penthouse apartment in um in this
beautiful skyviews Tower in Dubai and I
have a few watches but I don't have so
much anymore and uh honestly speaking
um money gives you freedom and freedom
gives you happiness right and all these
materialistic things I don't think they
make you happy they make you more
satisfied right they definitely make you
less happy and they can help other
factors which can make you happy of
course if you have a lot of money you
can pay for operations for you can
retire your family all of these things
definitely make you happy so money
indirectly can make you happy but these
materialistic things I I got the
pleasure and at the moment I don't feel
it too much I wear these chains I have
like I walk around in like five dollar
t-shirts and sometimes I like the easy
lifestyle I'm like bare feet at the
moment
I'm walking around Barefoot and um I
drink coconuts
um and I'm just as satisfied as as
usually so everyone watching this be
inspired by all the materialistic stuff
I have it's nice to be inspired and it's
nice to have this as like a material
goal so it keeps you grinding but make
sure you don't attach your your feeling
of worth this or something too much to
it make sure you you know that there are
more important things in life which is
like laugh
health happiness and wealth is just like
some supporting factor and if you don't
lose this out of your mind then I think
you have the right goals and yeah
that's mine I think that's really well
said um so just finally what are you
um what are your goals right now
if you know money's sorted and things
like that like from a personal
standpoint what's the goal it's sorted
that doesn't mean I don't want more
because I think money is something like
a scorecard right I like success I like
to succeed I like to to to work and see
I'm doing a good job and I think money
is like a scorecard showing you you did
well this was good here you have to
improve so it's like a game and I like
it I want to continue with that but I
have of course a lot of other goals
eventually I want to have a family but I
have a family but I want to build my own
family eventually of course
um I like to build companies so I am
actually working on on some projects as
well and in terms of Charity I'm like
building schools I built like um with
help two schools in Tulum one Ibiza one
in Kenya now I'm working on one school
in Thailand and I'm looking out for more
projects eventually I want to build a
thousand schools I don't know if it's
going to be easy or not but you want to
have high goals right so the all of
these are my goals and um in general I
just want to be happy spread happy
Fitness Good Vibes and yeah have a good
life
that's nice that sounds amazing um and
I'm sure that you're going to build a
thousand schools and and make that
difference
um Chris I want to thank you so much for
coming on it's been such a pleasure and
so fascinating hearing your take on the
markets where you think it's going what
life is like in Dubai um and all your
goals thank you so much for coming on
thank you also for having me and
everyone watching this support this lady
like the video share it and um leave
some comments down below I'm gonna be
after the video I go into the comment
section I want to see what you guys have
to say thanks for watching thank you so
much guys don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe and we'll see you
all next week bye bye the Leia hail plan
show